Tim et ses associés ont fondé une entreprise
avec 2 millions de dollars.
L'année suivante, ils sont à court d'argent.
Nombre d'entreprises auraient fermé. Mais Tim a choisi de se battre.
Il a pompé ses 11 cartes de crédit
et a accumulé une dette personnelle à 6 chiffres.
Et ce n'était pas suffisant.
Alors pendant 2 ans, une semaine sur deux, au moment de payer les salaires,
il a demandé à ses employés de sacrifier leur salaire.
Et ça a marché !
Plus de 50 personnes ont reporté 2 millions de dollars,
et 10 ans plus tard,
Pandora vaut des milliards.
Quand on est convaincu qu'il y a un moyen
de dépasser ou contourner l'adversité,
que le repli n'est jamais une option,
on peut surmonter les obstacles les plus grands.
Voici donc la deuxième morale :
sacrifier son égo et abandonner tout complexe de supériorité.
Voilà un acte effrayant.
C'est admettre sa vulnérabilité, son besoin des autres.
C'est peut-être même admettre
que nous ne sommes pas aussi spécial que nous aimons l'imaginer.
Stéphanie Forrester, dans « Amour, gloire et beauté »,
pensait être jolie et privilégiée.
Elle pensait être si spéciale,
qu'elle ne se mêlait pas avec la plèbe de la vallée,
et s'assurait que Brooke, fille de la vallée, le savait.
Après 25 ans de combats épiques,
Stéphanie tombe malade et laisse entrer Brooke.
Elles se réconcilient,
les ennemies jurées deviennent âmes sœurs
et Stéphanie meurt dans les bras de Brooke.
La leçon à retenir est celle-ci :
abandonnez votre égo.
Tout ne tourne pas autour de vous.
Ça tourne autour de nous.
Notre capacité à jouir du bonheur,
à aimer et à améliorer notre vécu
ne peut se concrétiser que si on se rend vulnérable,
et qu'on accepte de prendre nos responsabilités
pour nos actions et nos inactions,
un peu à l'image de Howard Schultz, le patron de Starbucks.
Après avoir été un super président,
Howard a quitté son poste en 2000.
Starbucks a dépassé ses capacités assez rapidement
et les actions ont chuté en bourse.
Howard est revenu en 2008,
et la première chose qu'il fit
fut de présenter ses excuses aux 180 000 employés.
Il a présenté ses excuses.
Et ensuite, il a sollicité leur aide, leur sincérité et leurs idées.
Aujourd'hui, Starbucks a plus que doublé ses bénéfices nets depuis son retour.
Sacrifions donc notre désir d'avoir raison et d'être en sécurité tout le temps.
Ça n'aide personne, surtout pas nous.
Sacrifier son égo, donc.
La morale numéro trois :
l'évolution existe.
Nous ne sommes pas faits pour être des personnages statiques.
A la télé, être statique signifie être ennuyeux.
Être ennuyeux signifie être viré.
Les protagonistes sont censés grandir et changer.
A la télé, ces changements dynamiques
prennent parfois la forme de transitions brutales,
par exemple, quand un personnage est joué par un certain acteur un jour
et par un nouvel acteur le lendemain.
Le changement de casting est le pain quotidien des séries.
Durant ces 20 dernières années,
4 actrices différentes ont incarné une même protagoniste, Carly Benson,
dans « Alliances et trahisons ».
Chaque nouvelle actrice a provoqué un changement
dans la vie et la personnalité du personnage.
On pouvait certes retrouver l'essence de Carly,
mais le personnage et la narration sont adaptés à l'acteur qui l'incarne.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour nous ?
Nous ne pouvons pas changer de visage dans notre vie,
mais nous pouvons évoluer.
On peut tracer un cercle autour de nos pieds et y rester cloîtré
ou nous pouvons ouvrir notre esprit aux opportunités,
comme Carly, étudiante en infirmerie devenue propriétaire d'un hôtel.
Ou comme Julia Child.
Julia était une espionne durant la deuxième guerre mondiale.
A la fin de la guerre, elle s'est mariée, a déménagé en France
et a décidé de monter une école culinaire.
Julia, ses livres et ses émissions télévisées,
ont révolutionné la manière dont l'Amérique cuisine.
On peut tous provoquer des changements dans nos vies,
évoluer et nous adapter.
Nous faisons des choix,
mais il arrive que la vie choisisse pour nous et nous n'avons pas le choix.
Nous sommes surpris de plein front.
On gît par terre, le souffle coupé,
on a besoin d'être ressuscité.
A ce moment, nous remercions la morale numéro 4 des séries :
la résurrection est possible.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
En 1983, dans « Des jours et des vies »,
Stefano Di Mera meurt après une attaque cardiaque.
Mais pas tout à fait, car en 1984,
il meurt quand sa voiture fait un plongeon dans l'eau du port
et il est de retour en 1985, avec un cancer au cerveau.
(Rires)
Mais avant que le cancer ne le tue,
Marlena tire sur lui, et il meurt, tombant du podium d'un défilé de mode.
Cela durera 30 ans.
(Rires)
Même devant sa dépouille,
nous ne nous laissions pas leurrer.
Il y a une bonne raison de l'appeler le Phénix.
Le message est le suivant :
tant que l'émission continue,
tant qu'on respire,
rien n'est permanent.
La résurrection est possible.
Bien sûr, comme dans la vraie vie,
les séries télévisées ont une fin.
En décembre 2009, CBS a annulé mon émission, « Ainsi va le monde ».
On a tourné le dernier épisode en juin 2010.
Cela représente six mois d'agonie
et j'en ai bu la lie jusqu'à la fin.
Bien que nous étions en pleine récession
et que des millions de personnes peinaient à trouver du boulot,
je croyais que tout irait bien.
J'ai abandonné l'appartement de Brooklyn,
et avec les enfants, nous avons déménagé chez les beaux-parents,
en Alabama.
(Rires)
Trois mois plus tard, rien n'allait bien.
C'est à cette époque que j'ai regardé le dernier épisode
et que j'ai compris que la série n'était pas la seule victime.
J'en étais une aussi.
J'étais sans emploi et j'habitais au deuxième étage
chez mes beaux-parents.
Et ça, c'est amplement suffisant pour mortifier n'importe qui.
(Rires)
Mais je savais que mon récit n'était pas encore fini.
Ça ne pouvait pas être le cas.
Je devais simplement puiser dans mes connaissances sur les séries.
Je devais être courageuse comme Erica, refuser d'abandonner la partie.
Chaque jour, je prenais la décision de me battre.
Je devais aussi être vulnérable, comme Stéphanie,
et sacrifier mon égo.
Je devais demander de l'aide, souvent, et au-delà des frontières.
Je devais être flexible, à l'image de Carly,
et améliorer mes compétences, mon état d'esprit et mes circonstances.
Je devais enfin montrer de la résilience, comme Stefano,
et ressusciter et ranimer ma carrière,
comme le phénix qui renaît de ses cendres.
Et j'ai enfin obtenu un entretien.
Après 15 ans d'activité dans les infos et le divertissement à la télé
et 9 mois sans emploi.
Cet entretien, en fait,
m'a ouvert les portes d'un boulot de débutant.
J'avais 37 ans
et je revenais d'entre les morts.
Nous traversons tous des expériences qui ressemblent à des épilogues,
mais nous pouvons les transformer en prologue.
Un peu comme Tina, qui a survécu miraculeusement à sa chute d'une falaise.
Comme je n'aime pas laisser traîner le suspens,
Tina et Cord ont divorcé, c'est vrai,
mais ils se sont remariés trois fois,
avant que la série ne soit retirée des ondes en 2012.
Rappelez-vous donc ceci :
tant que votre cœur bat,
il n'est jamais trop tard pour changer le récit de votre vie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)